see this game finish quite soon
unfortunately for mamajaro if the queen
is hanging you have to move her no
matter where you go if Magnus wants to
keep it super safe he takes this Pawn
gets the Queen's off the board clear
Pawn advantage or you can even take this
Pawn remember this one is still hanging
it's attacked three times okay manager
puts his Queen in the middle of the
board but is this queen just gonna get
trapped at some point
uh I guess his idea if the white Pawn
steps forward to attack the queen which
it has just done is to give up his
Knight but you're gonna be a whole piece
down and we see the black queen trapped
it's captured the White Queen is
captured but at the end Magnus just wins
a knight for free and Shaq has decided
he's had enough of that and Magnus takes
the point wow that was a quick game a
quick day three games Magnus wins them
all and takes three points against
chakra mom and yarov wow mine is Carlson
walking off he must be super happy
three wins in his match against mom